art I am serious recycling do this
interview right now I have truly wanna
make heroes from wrestling back in the
eighties to movies
to politics and now a guy that i truly
truly admire
and head of the great which is why I
wear these crazy had bound and we're
doing this on some super crazy
high-tech connection governor Jesse
Ventura how are you there
day mom doing terrific are you doing I
am doing well I cannot begin to tell you
the technical hurdles
that we had to jump through to make this
happen but that is the proof that you
truly
are off the grid so can you tell us a
little bit about that just
for stop well I'm aw I'm off the grid I
decided to do with your shot
right after I left office as governor
because I was young enough to go on an
adventure and I decided to do it
show we ventured down your way down shop
for the border about a thousand miles
and
I bought a home that time an hour from
pavement in an hour from electricity
and I've been living down here now often
on for going on a
years and now now that I have a show I
may be down here permanently would not
returning to the United States soon
because I love it down your offer great
I love the people where I live
and it's now the creation of my show
are broadcasting back into america as
opposed to looking at america from the
outside looking in
as oppose the inside looking out yet so
why does someone who has commercial
success
as an actor in a wrestler and then who
has political
successive staggering Peru political
success actually
why do you feel that you had to go off
the grid well I didn't feel I have to
but i i just felt I wanted an adventure
I was turning
at the time I would just gone over 50 in
your window of opportunity in time
it got to the point Dave I'll give it to
your blog yeah when you get to my agent
about sixty years old 62 I am now
time becomes more important than money
and show that was the reason I did it I
want to go on the adventure
I cannot if there's been a map and now I
it's paid off because I have the show
off the grid
yeah not you know we're in a situation
right now
were you criticize the US government
they might kill you with a draw me
closer
they don't well they don't have to take
you to court anymore
they don't have to charge with the crime
they don't have to go through due
process at all
began to shoot and kill you with a drone
if we come become a problem so
we gotta keep moving down your off the
grid to stay away from those drones
right so this is the stuff that we talk
about all the time over here but you are
actually living
who actually felt that I guess you have
enough influence or
your voice is powerful enough that you
actually felt I assume some sort of
threat either not maybe not spoken but
just sort of unspoken as a pair
today or not I never got threaten but I
I wish
I was being blackballed got there the
last book tour
the last book tour I did odd-numbered
the networks NBC CBS or ABC would have
me I'm
Fox won't have me I'm MSNBC won't have
she mm has me on occasionally shore
are this presented an opportunity what
happened I was doing a book to read
I saw on my schedule larry king and I
for women and Larry retired watch mash
and I walked into a hotel in New York a
mirror was larry king
yeah Larry said I'm on you should I'm on
ora .tv this is where you need to be
ensure we started discussing it now
explain to them I should well there's a
problem
I live off the grid for four to five
months a year
how could I possibly do a show for you
and they should that's not a problem we
have state-of-the-art technology
they should as long as we got energy
and as we get a clear shot up a
satellite we can do your show from
anywhere in the world
ensure that all of the event of the
great became the show
we thought Ben let's make rapper Scholl
that were off the grid
broadcasting back to be matched each
much the same I don't know if you're old
enough to remember
but when Wolfman Jack first yep a good
frame a shock jock duty in Iraq
way before Howard Stern up the bush
speak about the Wolfman with all the
teenage kids I remember a
was up but they wouldn't let the Wolfman
broadcast from the United States
sure we had to broadcast from Mexico in
the United States
and that's what we all believed as
teenagers about the Wolfman
so I'm just trying to use a mule Wolfman
Jack thing year
I going outside the country for real and
broadcasting Bakiyev
alright well so let's talk about that
though the heart out why you're outside
the country I mean I think you see this
this country much the way I see it in
it's a country that you love
and you want to be better but seems
really broken right now right
totally are I blame the Democrats and
Republicans both of them
equally as bad as each other they are
the problem they are not the solution
they have been in charge for a hundred
and fifty years now
look at the shape were in I just saw
statistically Dave the other day
a baby born when it takes its first
breath a rare in the United States
lamberth
miss fifty thousand dollars in debt are
fifty grand in debt
when you take your first prepare who's
responsible for this
the Democrats and Republicans they've
been in charge for a hundred and fifty
years
they've destroyed our country and we've
got to take it back from a
yeah so speaking taking it back so you
were someone that you started taking it
back because you
as an independent at the time became
governor I've Minnesota which
in retrospect 02 that almost seem crazy
that that actually worked
because now it almost seems like we
could never have an independent
not true at all not I proved that it
does work and we only raised three
hundred thousand dollars they
ya 98 to elect me governor 300 gram I
actually
made more money being governor than what
I spent to give it
I don't think there's another elected
official nationally
who can make that statement in 50 years
yeah that they made more money doing the
job done what be spent to get it
know it could happen I'll tell you right
now I
out all making a bold here we are on
page program
I'll give you a bold prediction into it
with their iPad
if I could get ballot access in all 50
states
and if I were guaranteed to be allowed
in the debates
I would be your next president in 2016 I
lesson at I I'm with you you have my
support I do everything
I can I write the letter I want to talk
about some other from the other more
points up with get out about tix per
minute I
I just watched the the running man this
week
and at the beginning I did there is this
preamble where they talk about what
america is going to be like in 2017
and it's about a militarized state and
an economic collapse and depleted
batteries are the not I'm watching this
Megan
they're just three years off because it
it's basically
happening now did you realize that that
movie
although we have we don't have reality
jail just yet but I think we probably
were reality media
do you realize that movie was gonna be
so ahead of its time
no really I didn't you know it was a fun
movie to do with richard Dawson an
arnold in all the happy hours
at the premise of the show he do you
know who actually wrote the running man
are you aware that
you know what I did my research before I
don't remember I had
tell me please well here's it well
here's the be all the running man was a
are short story written in a book buyer
a writer named Richard Bachman
well that was a pseudonym for Stephen
King Stephen King wrote the running man
is that right I can't believe it you
know when I asked what I was doing
research before I watched it again the
other day
I would have sworn it was a Philip K
Dick because that was all his
his future and no yeah nope Stephen King
Stephen King wrote under the pseudonym
Richard Bachman he wrote the running man
and what it is it's a game show or the
future well with reality TV like it is
today
and when you look at where we're at
right now in 2017
the running man might be real H three
years away
yeah it really between ratings and are
poor profit prisons which we already
have a definite possibility
so I gotta ask you when you did that
movie and you did predator both with
arnold schwarzenegger
did you guys ever do you have a
political talk to do everything a you
know what maybe
maybe we'll be governors one day where
you think not a bit
you know when we did predator in fact I
did predator in are all came up to me I
miss at mister just three
my next film the running man there's a
part you're perfect for I hope you will
do it
well it always get when you deal with
Hollywood
when the star of the film watch %um is
be home
it gives you great leverage on
negotiating the app
that mary had a little high alert where
when the star wants you in the film that
means you've got should leverage when it
comes time to negotiate then
believe me I exploited that leverage
well speaking up leverage did you get to
keep the gun
literally the coolest done probably in
the history of filmmaking did they let
you keep it
no not at all that's the helicopter may
be gone no I was the first person in
predator 2 should have held it shoots
shop
seven thousand rounds a minute I think
something like that
it's a it's a gavel in god knows what it
is rich I was shooting a full ammo load
didn't kick that much just torque to the
left a little cuz
the barrel swing counterclockwise but
the unique thing about the governor's
Arts electronically fire there's no
trigger
they would run battery cables up my
pants legging out misplace remember the
weapon
and their I could be guy in the bushes
I was time for me to shoot he touched
the two adds to the car batteries large
start firing wow that is unbelievable
what what was your classic line there do
you remember it
I ain't got time to bleed I there it is
there it is
what I got two more things work as I
know I know you're busy what do you
think it was
about the eighties about bat time
between the wrestling thing in the
movies you did
what was so cool about the eighties that
so many people obviously myself included
have such like great nostalgia for for
that time
well the raid but what happened was
wrestling with national all of a sudden
nearly
you had been 26 regionalized territories
you did come out at the carnival world
it had gone into the 26 region wise
territories
and all these promoters 26 I'm really
were kinda like the Mafia up
nobody ever cross their lines item in
the eighties came young Vince McMahon
junior Natrona
Vince McMahon senior what he did all
nobody any allegiance
and he had a vision and along with that
came cable television
he started buying up cable TV and he
took
wrestling national and he took it to
levels we never
I'll never forget the night we did NBC
the first night
NBC's Saturday Night mean about I
remember we altered
where we alternated every three to four
weeks were Saturday Night Live
and the greatest one ever was the second
season
they had madonna I opening up Saturday
Night Live she was red-hot
we came on three weeks later in blue her
numbers right out of the water
to this day rash laying shattered
tonight mean about
has the highest ratings for what they
call the weekend special
we actually did what was it up 34% share
well I mean what you know we always
think about the Golden Age a creamy and
and but that really was the golden age
arresting although it seems to be a
pretty nice comeback
my final question for you I'm gonna Andy
on a big one
who's running the show who is running
the show i I know your conspiracy guy I
know you know a lot about everything
who really at the end of the day is
right is is this the government is this
the only woman now D who is running the
show
you know I can't ship date even tell you
I can tell you who's doing it and I used
to not believe a matter luma na Bibi
used to not believe im
world government would be rather
but I'm somewhat change my mind now in
the investigation drive down in the
things I've watched a machine and I'm 62
years old now
it seems to me my dish strange I don't
believe
that our president runs our country
anymore because
the classic example was Brock Obama when
he ran now
he said he would call was get mall he
said he would do all be strange
and then the moment you got no of fresh
most things we're all for gotten
our foreign policy there's no difference
in our foreign policy
between george bush and Barack Obama at
all
none whatsoever in show somebody else in
to me it's gotta be the powerful money
people it's gotta be the Federal Reserve
in the bankers
who control the money because if you
control the money
you control everything yeah well you
said well we talk about every day
governor Richard truly truly truly an
honor to talk a good talk to you all day
but I know you got some other things to
do upgrade provided upgrade your pretty
busy I think that much
well i you like a shed at the top part
about being off the grid is
every day it's 85 and sunny day I
all right now pat i i really do
appreciate it and I look forward to
following you
and we'll see what happens but you gotta
now i hear all winter to promise you
that
are a very well I appreciate the young
church you guys are doing a great job
keep up the great work keep Obama stop
there
in between all of us will destroy the
mainstream media outlet for wrestling
internet
it ready mainstream media you're next in
line
we're gonna put you down X mainstream
media